I will say this about Florida
eyes are in the news a lot
but the latest Florida news is the one
that has got me just [__] shocked
everybody
uh leprosy
it's like Florida's like coven [__] you
hold my beer
I'm bringing back some [__] medieval
[__] right now yeah they talked about
this in The Hobbit nobody knows anything
about this this is
what the for the leprosy and I was in
Jacksonville last night you'll never
convince me it didn't start there but um
time I go to Jacksonville and I drive in
there I'm like so this is where
everything bad started right here I
think that's ground zero right [__]
there for sure
can I tell you why summer is my [__]
favorite time to come here is because
all the people
UK are bright red
they've never seen the sun like this
before
and they're [__] straight up Tomatoes
like you you can pick them out you're
like you're not from here huh I'm like
no I'm looking at my face I can't move
it look it's amazing
I'm sure you guys see him walking down
the street he's like you're from UK how
did you know your [__] face is
falling off your face that's how I know
[Music]
one of my favorites I'm bummed out I
told Jacob he didn't know this I I
bummed out that Holy Land is gone
it's a such a bummer man
yo it was such a bummer to see happy
Jesus on the freeway just
the [__] is just
I've never seen that Jesus before just
[__] thumbs up Jesus you don't see
that dude too often
I will say this about Florida it's
definitely more humid than I'm
used to
my balls never look old until I get too
far
but as soon as I get here it's like all
the elasticity just drains
out of the sack just like
yeah I I don't know how people wear
short shorts here but that is
it's risky I'll tell you that it's risky
you're not doing any High leg kicks
that's for sure